tout comme carbone dans les usines que
ça soit nos émissions directes ou alors
des émissions liées à la production
d'électricité nous en avons aujourd'hui
dans le monde donc la conscience
écologique aussi existe en russie
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait l'europe on
a vu des personnes gravement blessées on
a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine au mitan la presse s'était
déchaînée sur ce qu'était réellement le
noyau dur du dispositif de maintien
d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a une fait le premier pays d'europe
à franchir le pas face à nouvelle vague
épidémique dès lundi l'autriche va
confiné l'ensemble de sa population elle
a également décidé de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire à partir de
février juste à côté l'allemagne impose
des restrictions pour l'on vacciné
menés pour l'accès à certains lieux
publics
[Musique]
chaise ou emmanuelle bach on promet de
ne pas confiner les non-vaccinés le
président est-il peu le passé à lyster
suffit en face à lithaire très contesté
en guadeloupe depuis quatre jours
maintenant illustration avec des
manifestations à l'appel des
organisations syndicales émaillées
parfois de violence à le gouvernement a
annoncé l'envoi de deux cents policiers
et gendarmes en confort
dans l'actualité également fait volte
face de narendra modi en inde à la
surprise générale le premier ministre
indien va abroger trois lois de la
réforme agricole qui suscite à des
manifestations massives d'agriculteurs
depuis un an une décision qui intervient
avant d'importantes élections notamment
au bout de jardin état agricole
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france et on commence
avec cette information de jour qui
secoue l'europe sur le front sanitaire
l'autriche var confiné toute sa
population dès lundi en réponse à la
nouvelle vague épidémique sur le vieux
continent elle il s'agit d'une mise sous
cloche de vingt jours avec une
évaluation de la situation au bout de
dix jours par ailleurs le pays va
imposer la vaccination à partir du 1er
février dans le même temps l'agencé
européenne des médicaments approuvent
l'utilisation de la pilule anti coville
de merckx en cas d'urgence allaient
précision d'adrien fente nous
il y avait le tadjikistan le
turkménistan ou encore le vatican il y
aura désormais aussi l'autriche face à
la résurgence des cas de kovy de 19,1
confinement de trois semaines jusqu'au
13 décembre a été décidé par la
chancellerie autrichienne
mais le pays va surtout devenir le
premier de l'union européenne à rendre
la vaccination obligatoire dès le 1er
février 2022
malgré des mois de persuasion malgré des
campagnes médiatiques intensive malgré
des discussions dans divers médias nous
n'avons pas réussi à convaincre
suffisamment de personnes de se faire
vacciner
augmenter durablement le taux de
vaccination je pense que nous sommes
tous d'accord et le seul moyen de sortir
de ce cercle vicieux des différentes
vagues du virus et des mesures de
confinement ne voulons pas d'une
cinquième vague nous ne voulons pas
d'une sixième et d'une septième vague 15
exposants
la décision d'imposer la vaccination
fait suite à une première campagne jugée
insuffisante avec seulement 66 % de la
population pleinement vacciner un
chiffre en dessous de la moyenne
européenne et même si quinze mille
nouveaux cas ont encore été enregistrés
ce jeudi la population est partagée sur
ces nouvelles mesures ne sont pas vains
je trouve cela terrible les gens ont
besoin de liberté pour moi c'est tout
simplement inacceptable orale
fortis en sommes extrêmement mécontent
de cette situation en tant que citoyenne
je dois dire qu'il n'ya peut-être pas
d'autre solution je n'en ai aucune idée
en tout cas nous espérons rouvrir le 13
décembre et avoir peut-être dix jours de
plus pour vendre car pour nous ce
confinement est un désastre
c'est une mesure qui était attendue
depuis longtemps car nous avons vu
depuis quelques semaines à quel point la
situation était difficile dans les soins
intensifs de tous les hôpitaux rond et
bien sûr même si c'est moins agréable de
rester à la maison pendant les
prochaines semaines je pense que c'est
la seule bonne mesure à prendre et oui
avec l'obligation de vaccination on peut
espérer enfin voir le bout du tunnel
ce samedi en protestation face à ces
décisions gouvernementales
une manifestation est prévue à vienne
soutenu par le parti de la liberté
d'autriche un rassemblement sans son
leader anti vaccins herbert tickle testé
positif aux coronavirus
et puis à fait nouvelles restrictions en
allemagne et non vaccinés exclu de
certains lieux publics par ailleurs à
tous les marchés de noël en bavière sont
annulés la chancelière angela merkel qui
doit bientôt quitter le pouvoir appelle
la population à se faire vacciner on
fait le point avec julien du rouet
sérielle bruche
l'allemagne dans une situation hautement
dramatique
au lendemain de cette déclaration de la
chancelière allemande angela merkel et
de la mise en place de nouvelles
restrictions l'autorité sanitaire mais
on garde le gouvernement allemand elle
juge les nouvelles mesures insuffisantes
au vu mohcine gameflow touche l'isthme
zweig et nous devons maintenant fermé
les vannes la règle des 2 g est
importante mais dans la situation
actuelle cela ne suffit malheureusement
plus nous devons également réduire
massivement les contacts pour ralentir
la propagation du virus cela implique
par exemple de rester chez soi si
possible d'annuler les grandes
manifestations de réduire le nombre de
personnes lors des petites
manifestations de fermer les hotspots
comme les bars et les clubs mal aérée
despotisme il ne s'agit plus depuis
longtemps de foyers isolés toute
l'allemagne n'est qu'un seul et grand
foyer épidémique
nous sommes dans une situation d'urgence
nationale
l'une des principales mesures adoptées
ce jeudi et la limitation de la vie
sociale des non vaccinés une mesure qui
concerne les länder où le seuil
d'hospitalisation dépasse trois malades
du cobp id pour cent mille habitants
c'est déjà le cas dans 12 des 16 länder
allemands si le seuil des passes six
malades même les personnes vaccinées ou
guéris devront présenter un test des
restrictions strictes qui ont pour but
de soulager le système de santé
et même ça nous avons toujours dit que
nous ne voulions pas surcharger notre
système de santé nous savons
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas
respecter cet engagement sur l'ensemble
du territoire heureusement nous avons
encore des capacités à de nombreux
endroits mais il est vraiment temps
d'agir sur l'autre
autre nouvelle mesure l'obligation
vaccinale du personnel hospitalier et
des maisons de retraite une décision
prise dans le but de protéger les
groupes les plus vulnérables face à la
flambée des cas jusqu'ici le
gouvernement allemand s'était toujours
refusé d'imposer la vaccination à
certaines catégories professionnelles
en france on n'en est pas encore là à
cinq mois de la présidentielle emmanuel
macron promet de ne pas confiner les
non-vaccinés le président préfère miser
sur le pass sanitaire c'est ce qu'il a
confié dans une interview accordée au
quotidien lors d'un déplacement dans le
nord selon lui je cite lé pays qui
confine les non vaccinés sont ceux qui
n'ont pas mis en place le pass
sanitaires et puis par ailleurs sachez
que l'on attend en france une commande
de 50 mille gélules antico widmer qu'à
la fin de l'année et la haute autorité
de santé recommande une dose de rappel
de vaccin à partir de 40 enfants
l'exécutif dont qui table sur un pass
sanitaires très contesté en guadeloupe
depuis quatre jours on manifeste contre
cette mesure et l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants ont manifesté à
l'appel d'organisations syndicales pneus
brûlés routes aient accès au chu bloquer
certaines écoles ont dû fermer pour
parer à cette situation une réponse
sécuritaire de la part du gouvernement
qui annonce
l'envoi de 200 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires lé ministère d outre mer
et de l'intérieur condamne les violences
des manifestations qui perturbent le
fonctionnement des hôpitaux écouter
cette réaction
depuis cette semaine et à les barrages
routiers qui pénalise énormément le
personnel qui viennent de tout horizon
que ce soit médical ou paramédical
donc c'est vrai qu'on est obligé
d'attendre que tout le monde soit
présent pour démarrer et d'attendre la
relève aussi qu'elle soit présente pour
continuer donc ça c'est un pacte mais
chacun il donne du sien un médecin
anesthésiste remplace une infirmière
anesthésiste un brancardier un
aide-soignant remplace un an brancardier
moi même je suis sûr fin de post amm a
même en même temps et comme ça on peut
on tout retenir philippe bélair
secrétaire général de la cgtg santé
guadeloupe remettent en cause les choix
du gouvernement en matière de
vaccination l'écoutent
quoi qui a été fait en termes de
vaccination n'est pas le bon nous ce
qu'on dort revendique c'est simplement
qu'on arrête cette gestion qui pour nous
et des folles qui cherchent du revient
très cher et qui n'a pas d'autre
résultat
c'est ça pour le monde et il avait dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas de vaccination
obligatoire il avait dit qu'il n'était
pas question que me à nouveau le rookie
be really a dit une chose et son
contraire nous n'y voyons pas une
pension changement que là il faut
changer de boîte qu'il faut changer
il faut impérativement qu'il y ait une
véritable gestion sanitaire et non une
gestion affiris comme c'est le cas
depuis deux ans et du côté des états
unis on ouvre la voie à une troisième
dose pour les adultes du pays les
autorités sanitaires ont validé ce
vendredi cette troisième injection dans
un contexte de regain des quatre coville
on retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas boni
thomas bonsoir alors cette nouvelle
étape de la campagne vaccinale pourrait
démarrer dès ce week end
oui pour cela il ne reste plus que le
feu vert de l'acide ici le centre de
lutte contre les maladies aux états unis
pour donner une autorisation complète à
cette troisième dose à l'ensemble des
adultes de plus de 18 ans aux états unis
jusqu'à présent se booster shot comme on
l'appelle ici était réservée aux
américains de plus de 65 ans aux
personnes présentant des risques de
comorbidité ou encore aux personnes qui
sont davantage exposés au virus
notamment de par leur profession c'est
d'ailleurs aussi dans une volonté de
clarification que l'agencé américaine
des médicaments a donné son feu vert à
cette troisième dose pour l'ensemble des
adultes dans le pays une annonce qui
intervient alors que les autorités
sanitaires américaines font part de leur
inquiétude à l' approche de l'hiver et
aussi parce que le nombre de cas
quotidien de personnes contaminées par
le commis 19 augmente aux états unis 85
mille nouveaux cas ont été détectés dans
la journée d'hier alors cette troisième
dose sera sans doute plébiscité par une
partie des américains qui sont déjà
convaincus par l'efficacité du vaccin et
de se booster shot mais on le sait que
la difficulté pour le gouvernement de
joe biden c'est de convaincre les
récalcitrants il ya encore 60 millions
d'américains qui n'ont pas été vaccinées
moins de 60% de la population américaine
est entièrement vacciner à l'heure où je
vous parle et les mesures d' obligation
de vaccination de la maison blanche ont
été suspendus elles sont bloquées dans
un bras de fer juridique en ce moment
d'ailleurs c'est un bras de fer qui est
aussi politique pour preuve hier par
exemple le gouverneur de l'état de
floride était dans la ville de brandon
où il a signé une série de mesures
visant à empêcher toute instauration
d'un pass vaccinale dans son état merci
beaucoup avoue thomas bonnet pour toutes
ces précisions en direct depuis
washington
en inde à la surprise générale narendra
modi renonce à 3 loi de la réforme
agricole il s'agit pour le premier
ministre indien de faire cesser à la
vague de contestation et la colère des
agriculteurs une volte face alors que
doit se tenir prochainement à des
élections dans plusieurs états clefs
fortement peuplées de paysans dont le
punjab on voit cela avec cyrielle
benavides bullion
scènes de joie dans les rues de xingu
dans la banlieue de new delhi ces
agriculteurs applaudissent l'annnonce du
premier ministre darrell drame audi
d'abroger trois lois de la réforme
agricole votée en septembre l'année
dernière
aujourd'hui je demande aux agriculteurs
qui protestent en ce jour pieux de
l'anniversaire de la naissance de la
gourou nanak s'il vous plaît retournez
chez vous dans vos fermes et dont vous
fermez
prenons un nouveau départ et les worgens
mitchell en paix aie aie aie gauche ou
droite
mais elle se l'est fait un gameplay un
appel au calme les réformes mises en
place avait provoqué la colère des
petits exploitants qui manifestent
massivement dans tout le pays depuis
près d'un an ces lois devaient permettre
aux agriculteurs de choisir les
entreprises à qui ils vendent leurs
produits mais aussi de fixer leurs
propres prix une libéralisation du
marché qui aurait entraîné la
disparition du prix de soutien minimal
une protection garantie par l'état
ces modifications avaient inquiété grand
nombre d'agriculteurs
craignant de devoir brader leurs
marchandises aux grandes entreprises
pour les écouler nous distribuons déjà
des bonbons à l'occasion de gourou pour
hab et maintenant nous sommes heureux de
cette annonce de maudit si elle est
finalement traiter cela la rendra
permanente
nous saluons l'annoncé du premier
ministre maudit mais les agriculteurs ne
partirons pas d'ici tant que la loi
n'aura pas été abrogée par le parlement
de la même manière que la loi a été
adoptée par le parlement
nous sommes heureux mais nous
agriculteurs ne faisons pas tellement
confiance au gouvernement je n'y croirai
que lorsqu'il tend poseront le papier au
parlement et nous donnerons une garantie
de prix de soutien minimum un revirement
de maudit calculer ce vendredi marque le
jour de gourou pour à ben laden
anniversaire de la naissance de guru
nanak fondateur du sikhisme une religion
partagé par de nombreux paysans
protestataires mais qui intervient aussi
à lapproche d'importantes élections dans
plusieurs états
on en vient à la crise migratoire qui
perdure à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne avec des
milliers de réfugiés toujours à bloquer
links assura qu'une grande partie a été
transféré sur la base du volontariat
vers un centre d'accueil hier à les
gardes-frontières polonais ont arrêté 45
migrants 431 exilés sont retournés en
irak par un vol de rapatriement des
exilés qui ont abandonné l'espoir de
traverser l'europe via la pologne
écouter certains d'entre eux
j'ai parlé aux membres de l'armée
biélorusse et franchement je leur ai
versé de l'argent juste pour qu'il me
laisse retourner à minsk je ne leur ai
pas dit que je retournais en irak car je
ne peux pas le dire je leur ai dit tout
ce que je veux c'est aller à minsk pour
faire soigner ma fille j'ai payé 700
dollars à l'un d'entre eux qui a loué un
taxi pour me ramener à minsk depuis la
frontière je m'étais mis d'accord avec
un contrebandier et je me suis dirigé
vers la frontière biélorusse j'ai réussi
à la traversée et j'ai atteint la zone
tampon entre la biélorussie et la
pologne la zone n'a pas de couverture de
téléphonie mobile j'ai donc été attrapé
par un garde biélorusse il a pris mon
passeport et mon téléphone portable et
m'a gardé dans la forêt je suis resté
cinq jours dans la forêt sans nourriture
sans eau et sans internet je vivais avec
ce que je trouvais sur le sol nous
étions dans la forêt la vie était très
mauvaise mais les biélorusses nous aider
ils nous fournissait de la nourriture de
l'eau et d'autres équipements
les polonais eux n'était pas gentil ils
utilisaient des gaz lacrymogènes sur nos
yeux il essayait de nous repousser
et sachez que la russie ne compte pas
fermer les yeux sur les provocations de
l'otan et de l'union européenne en
ukraine c'est ce qu'a affirmé ce
vendredi le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov à l'issue de
négociations avec son homologue suédoise
aline 2 le point avec notre
correspondante à moscou maylis des
stress
les dernières déclarations du chef de la
diplomatie russe confirme que les
relations entre moscou et l'otan reste
on ne peut plus tendue sagui lavrov a
déclaré que même si la russie était
ouverte au dialogue avec ses partenaires
occidentaux
elle avait tout à fait conscience des
agissements de l'alliance atlantique et
de l'union européenne en ukraine
winnie blue jam sokolova doivent nous
n'allons pas fermer les yeux sur ces
provocation grossière que nous voyons
chaque jour de la part des membres de
l'otan est de plus en plus souvent de la
part de l'union européenne y compris
dans sa tentative de faire le jeu des
militaristes en ukraine d'organiser une
sorte de mission militaire de formation
pour les ukrainiens de préparer l'armée
ukrainienne à ces mêmes actions doit le
menacent constamment en déclarant
qu'elle prendra le dombass par la force
ne voulons pas respecter les accords de
minsk l'ukraine qui portent atteinte à
la crimée russe
bijoux aéroports net mais
d'après sergueï lavrov la russie ne
permettra jamais que l'on menait ses
intérêts nationaux légitimes et elle
dispose de tous les moyens nécessaires
pour s'en assurer ces propos sont une
réponse à ceux tenus ce lundi par le
secrétaire général de l'otan
en plus si est seconde seguin en ce qui
concerne l'ukraine nous constatons une
fois de plus un renforcement important
des forces militaires russes nous
constatons une concentration
inhabituelle de force nous les voyons
près des frontières de l'ukraine mais
nous les voyons aussi en crimée en
territoire ukrainien occupés et par
conséquent nous appelons la russie à
être transparents sur ce qu'elle fait
nous appelons la russie à la désescalade
pour prévenir l'escaladé réduire les
tensions mais quand tu dis est claire à
ce que la chine inde entre le dews
tenshin l'heure n'est donc pas à
l'apaisement dans les relations entre
moscou et l'alliance atlantique qui se
sont dégradées ces
semaine depuis le 1er novembre la
mission de la russie auprès de l'otan et
celle de l'organisation militaire à
moscou sont suspendus une décision prise
par la russie après que le temps annoncé
début octobre l'expulsion de huit
diplomates russes soupçonnés
d'espionnage ainsi que la réduction des
accréditations de la mission russe à
bruxelles
cette situation humanitaire maintenant
très inquiétante en afghanistan depuis à
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
l'économie est quasi paralysée à
conséquence les conditions de vie des
afghans se dégrade très rapidement au
point qu'un million de personnes est
menacée par la famine notre envoyé
spécial antoine claireaux est à kaboul
l'économie afghane est en chute libre
plus d'un afghan sur deux est sans
emploi télé le bilan peu reluisant que
l'on peut faire du pays à l'heure
actuelle les ong tentent bien d'avertir
la communauté internationale de la
catastrophe humanitaire qui se profile
ces mêmes ong qui sont déjà très active
sur le terrain nous avons passé la
journée d'hier sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de kaboul et nous avons pu
observer plusieurs allers-retours
plusieurs atterrissages et décollages
d'appareils de l'onu ou encore de
médecins sans frontières et c'est dans
ce contexte que la russie a fourni une
aide humanitaire de 36 tonnes à
l'afghanistan une aide humanitaire plus
que bienvenus
décosse est extrêmement important car
aujourd'hui l'afghanistan et un bord
d'une crise humanitaire comme le rat
bande de nombreuses agences de presse et
les agences de l'onu un actionnaire s
est constitué
quand la chine en fait c'est à cause des
conflits et du changement récent de
gouvernement en afghanistan aujourd'hui
les afghans sont confrontés à de
nombreux défis à de nombreux problèmes
dans différents domaines de leur vie
c'est pourquoi nous avons vraiment
besoin d'une aide humanitaire d'une
coopération avec les pays amis du monde
entier
en plus pour la seconde
les ong craignent en plus que l'hiver
qui se profile soit particulièrement
difficile en effet le pays a connu cette
année une grave sécheresse autant de
facteurs qui font que les plus faibles
n'en sont que plus vulnérables tout
cas ce qu il faut orange vous savez nous
nous attendons à un hiver froid qui
arrivera dans quelques mois et cela
affectera beaucoup de personnes
vulnérables principalement les enfants
et les femmes qui rencontreront
différents types de problèmes faussetés
foot ça c'est ce qu'on lui fasse par
conséquent premier lieu la nourriture et
l'assistance médicale sont très
importantes pour nous et dans un second
temps des abris et des vêtements pour
que les gens n'aient pas droit pendant
l'hiver ronde
wintle
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
leur gouvernement n'a pas été reconnue à
l'international et des sanctions
économiques ont été adoptées contre le
pays des sanctions qui pèsent sur les
finances du pays et qui ne seront levés
que lorsque le gouvernement fournira
dégage des garanties concernant les
droits humains et les droits de la femme
à présent ce dossier délicat de la pêche
entre paris et londres et cette
déclaration cet après-midi d'emmanuel
mâcon nous allons continuer à nous
battre nous ne lâcherons pas nos
pêcheurs une façon de rectifier le tir
une annonce alors que les professionnels
de la pêche ont réagi avec colère à des
propos de la ministre de la mère annick
girardin qui a évoqué un plan
d'indemnisation pour les pêcheurs qui
perdrait à leur licence pour les eaux
britanniques
en france à lyon le quartier de la
guillotière dans la tourmente
l'insécurité et la sphère des habitants
et des commerçants certains ont même
décidé de fermer plus tôt et en appelle
aux pouvoirs publics amaya souplesse
la guillotière quartier bien connue de
lyon où l'insécurité et la colère des
commerçants se fait de plus en plus
ressentir
graphique recèle l'agression et bagarres
voilà à quoi sont confrontés les
propriétaires de commerces sur la place
gabriel péri épicentre du quartier une
situation qui s'est aggravée depuis
l'épidémie et la mise en place d
confinement des vacances
qui s'est multiplié depuis le
confinement avec
une insécurité qui est
qui est là au quotidien tous les jours
donc voilà
on n'en peut plus voudrait fermer a d
abord 30 mai les papes au ces pour moi
de faire ma 10e rang de par cette
insécurité grandissante
qui règne sur la place voilà parce que à
partir de 19 heures il ya une bande de
chacals cette bande de voyous il ya
beaucoup de gens qui jaune qui
stationnent sur la place qui vendent des
cigarettes de contrebande et qui font
régner une insécurité
certains sont même contraints de fermer
leur enseigne plutôt comme le casino le
mcdo lui ne procède qu'à la vente à
emporter
la nuit tombée le quartier devient moins
fréquentables selon un pharmacien
lyonnais et les clients désertent les
rues
si les commerçants ont alerté de
nombreuses fois la municipalité
il ne s'estime pas suffisamment entendue
il ya des dealers de cigarettes 10h de
substances
là
la ruée salle les gens sont plus en
sécurité et donc du coup résultat des
courses au bout d'un an et demi où on a
alerté la mairie on a alerté les édiles
de lyon
c'est pas passé grand chose
malheureusement pendant pendant nos
alertes et donc on en arrive aujourd'hui
à 1 à
un état où les clients de fui le
quartier le collectif la guillotière en
colère demandent aujourd'hui aux
autorités locales des actions concrètes
et rapides afin de mettre fin à la
délinquance qui selon eux gangrène le
quartier cette semaine à l'issue d'une
réunion entre les commerçants et acteurs
locaux le préfet du rhône s'est engagé à
établir une surveillance policière sur
la place gabriel péri jusqu'à minuit et
pendant 27 jours une bonne nouvelle qui
laisse planer une volonté d'apaisement à
seulement quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
à la france l'une des puissances de
seconde ce qui porte à croire que dans
ce genre de pays l'accès à internet
n'est plus une préoccupation
et bien détrompez vous cela s'appelle la
fracture numérique illustration à à
meaux en seine et marne avec ce
reportage de renault parquet et pierre
pissavy yvernault
pierre a emménagé dans son appartement
flambant neufs en juillet dernier mais
depuis plus de quatre mois il est sans
connexion internet résultat ils se
retrouvent sans accès téléphonique sans
accès à la toile et sans possibilité de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une offre de
chaînes payantes ce retraité bénévole
dans une association humanitaire
international est bloqué dans sa
communication quotidienne aujourd'hui
j'ai 50 % communication qui est
endommagé puisque aujourd'hui si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on n'a fait que
internet deviennent si vous voulez un
moyen de communication au niveau mondial
et pas accès j'ai pas accès ni à travers
mon ordinateur j'ai pas accès ni à
travers mon téléviseur je suis désolé
mais c'est pas acceptable
je suis vice-président enfin past
président d'une association humanitaire
est bon bien souvent j'ai des opérations
à faire notamment avec l'étranger et je
suis anti kiné avec ça j'ai l'impression
que orange ne se rend pas compte du
du service qu'il doit rendre à l'homme
le promoteur de cet immeuble multiplie
les démarches depuis sa livraison en
juillet dernier sans pour autant avoir
de date précise sur l'entamé des travaux
et du raccordement vous êtes avides de
vie sains pour le réseau adsl et un pour
le réseau fibré pour une somme globale
de 6100 euros et environ au centime près
et devait réaliser ces travaux pour
juillet à la date de livraison aux
différents acquéreurs et malheureusement
nous sommes en novembre et les travaux
n'ont toujours pas été réalisée si fait
si bien qu' aucun locataire propriétaire
résidant ne peut bénéficier du téléphone
de l'internet du réseau qui peut être en
droit est effectivement avoir dans cette
ville de seine-et-marne ses 11 co
propriétaires se bat toujours pour avoir
accès à internet certains se sont même
isolé et devrait demander une
compensation à orange la fracture
numérique touche bel et bien les grandes
villes du pays et pourrait peut-être
devenir l'un des enjeux de la prochaine
campagne présidentielle
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine de minutes restez
avec nous sur rt france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
nouvelle hausse de 12 6% pour les prix
du gaz au 1er octobre du côté des
carburants ce n'est pas mieux qu a pas
redonné un peu de marge pour pouvoir
d'achat l'exécutif est complètement
impuissant non les tailles vous fait pas
cadeau l'état c'est nous donc on se fait
des cadeaux à nous mêmes le problème
c'est que ça ne résout pas le problème
c'est le décale il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose de visible et b c'est axa
n'est pas visible en revanche vous
envoyez un chèque ces visites c'est pas
quand les matières premières explosent à
la hausse qu'il faut se poser la
question c'est avant tout vernet c'est
prévoir mais c'est pas seulement prévoir
sa réélection